well what is it that the straw or the
giant cocaine
[Music]
ooh that's messy that's yours not mine
place one pretzel on each side is that
inside the slice luckily there is such
thing as a Pinterest fail it's kind of
cute in a weird way yeah I like mine
it's like when you see that really derpy
dog you know it doesn't have long to
live but you still want to take it home
[Music]
don't look it over here cheater
I want you I already did mine oh my god
mine failed I'm failing I'm gonna game
[Music]
your steering something you want to make
sure that it goes through the most part
of the body and not just the holes
that's already there is this an
instruction video or oh I get it
alright that's cute I am I don't
understand how this is like a fun thing
to do just eat the doughnut like it will
stop being crazy just eat it can you
imagine having children
can we just like stick it in
why does yours have four eyebrows or
eyeballs rather plump up my marshmallow
so that it's nice and round this is fun
for like crafting and like talking
friends bringing people together
what the hell is it's to Christmas
mushroom they're heard the tale of the
Christmas shrew a nice little tax cut
out of holiday cocoa
[Music]
I really liked the gaming element to it
I think we were just too competitive we
with each other to be like I want to out
craft the other person and like at the
end of the day we still made something
that was cute and ideally edible moms
and dads that take time to make this
tacky you were the real heroes we don't
want to be like the originals you want
to be your own person at the end of the
day and you want your craft to reflect
that so yeah
[Music]